oh white house press secretary jinsaki
laughing off americans concerns about
crime now a furious national police
union demanding an apology joining us
live as always on a tuesday fox nation
host tommy lahren tommy great to see you
as always despite the overwhelming
evidence of crime ravaging our cities
and quite frankly our country on the
whole why does gensake and this white
house continue to remain blind to what
victims throughout our nation are going
through
well a couple things todd one it's a
huge political liability and number two
they're not seeing it firsthand they
have private security probably the best
security in the world so it doesn't
really touch and affect them but what i
would say to jen saki if she's confused
what soft on crime policies are she
should go to any american city
especially a democrat-run major city and
she should see it firsthand i can name
just a few things she should be looking
for they defund and demonize the police
movement crime reclassification crime
realignment no cash bail catch and
release which is happening not only in
american cities but at our lawless
southern border so she goes there she
can take a look firsthand and see
exactly the lawlessness and the soft on
crime policies that we're talking about
here on fox news and really in every
major city across the united states both
republicans and democrats then if she
really wants to have some fun she should
lock arms with our vice president kamala
harris and go right on down to that
southern border to see more of the
lawlessness and then i think that she
would know what we were talking about
yeah and then the fraternal order of
police are now demanding an apology for
that but kind of piggy backing off of
this defund the police movement stacey
abrams she spent more than a million
dollars on private security in 2021
despite her support to defund the police
so my question here is how in the same
breath is she going to pay boatloads of
money for private security but then try
and take away the security that sense of
security that the community and the
public has with police
it's a tale as old as time democrats
doing one thing and saying another i
believe it was representative cory bush
who said much the same thing her life
and her work was too important so she
needed private security and the rest of
us needed to suck it up and defund
police but the democrats are going to
pay for this come november midterms and
they're going to start realizing how
badly they're going to pay for this
probably starting in early summer and
then they're going to attempt to
gaslight us into believing that they
aren't for defining the police that they
aren't for soft on crime policies but
the american people are watching and we
are paying attention the sad thing to me
though todd and carly is how many
americans are going to be hurt or killed
while we wait for democrats to wake up
and see what's happening in our cities
we can't just wait for them to see the
political liability of all this we need
to let them know that this needs to be
handled urgently because it's a matter
of american safety and not political and
before i hand it off to todd i'd like
for both saki and people like stacey
abrams to tell this to the mother of
that one-year-old who was shot in the
head in the bronx a couple of weeks ago
that they wanted to fund the police and
take their security away from them it's
like we live in two different worlds
meantime tommy speaking of living in
different worlds your former governor
gavin newsom your buddy says he only
took off his mask to take a photo with
basketball legend magic johnson but fan
cam footage contradicts him turns out he
had that mask off a lot there at sophie
stadium during the nfc championship game
here he is defending himself
i was trying to be gracious and i made
him you know i mean i was trying to be
gracious and took the mask off for a
brief second but uh
no i urge people to continue wear them i
almost said i made a mistake he kind of
went there then didn't uh at this point
tommy should we expect anything
different from governor
french laundry
listen you cannot hide from that fan
camera but i think it's really important
that governor newsom broke some news to
us that you can't spread covid while
taking a photo that's a wonderful piece
of health and safety advice that i'm so
glad that we're hearing from governor
newsom
he's lying to the american people and
let's keep in mind meanwhile the
american students especially in his home
state of california are now expected to
wear medical grade mass as if they're
going to school at chernobyl but he can
have some fun with magic johnson and
take his mask off for a brief moment or
the entire game because again he is just
too important in his fun and his photo
ops just more important than the
comfortability and these learning
success of american students as well as
the rest of us who quite frankly would
just like to free our faces yeah who
cares that kids are drawing pictures of
themselves without noses and mouths yeah
who cares about as long as i can enjoy
the nfc championship game all is good or
all the teachers with no masks behind
them and the kids with a mask on it'll
be interesting to see what happens at
the super bowl at the same stadium in a
couple weeks i can guarantee the players
will be wearing helmets uh maybe tommy
larry we appreciate your time as always
thank you kindly hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now